Pearson Mercedes no one would ever guess
as a Mercedes
it has golden doors an engine roar
meaner than any Ferrari and a rear end
like a Lamborghini plus it's painted
some sort of army orange not the kind of
thing you'd expect from an esteemed but
reserved German luxury brand like
Mercedes but you'd be wrong this is the
1970 mercedes-benz C 111 only 15 of them
were made and there are 10 left in the
world today oh and did I mention that
only one of those 10 is drivable so I
felt pretty lucky that Mercedes decided
to ship it over to America for the
Pebble Beach Concours d'Elegance
complete with a distinguished German
handler who never let the car out of his
sight I mean the thing has worth more
than a million dollars I don't blame it
the C 111 is so special because of what
it meant for Mercedes at the time it was
experimental in almost every way the
suspension transmission tuning and even
interior technology were revolutionary
Mercedes even used the C 111 Series to
test diesel and turbo engines gol wing
doors and air conditioning driving the C
111 felt like a throwback to that same
era that gave us Led Zeppelin in Vietnam
crazy and free and aggressive and wrong
the thing can hit more than 180 miles
per hour on its four speed manual engine
and you can tell it wants to get there
fast that's thanks of course and part
two the super lightweight fiberglass
body shell and thanks to its three rotor
direct injection 370 horsepower wanker
so what became at the C 111 well
Mercedes made a C 112 in 1991 and even
took orders on it but this alas is one
of the beautiful icons we've probably
lost different scenery unless of course
you can get your hands on this one in
which case party on